the last tip and i'm all ears how do we
organize the fridge the home edit way
all right well let's take a look at it
okay you can see
all right all right drew
now that is a beauty yup she is a beauty
that that's way better than my game okay
how do i bring her home all right okay
so the very first thing you should
implement if you want to have an
organized fridge are clear bins it is
really helpful to divide categorize you
know exactly what you have when you're
running low on something you can see it
all and it's not just like a big
mish-mush right the second thing we
would say is with the clear bins
especially these you're able to stack
them so you're able to take advantage of
the vertical space which is otherwise
goes unused and the fridge you have such
limited space that you want to use every
inch wherever you can this is truly
maximizing the height and we love a
label we love a label with everything
and by the way a rainbow organizing
system is also a label it's a it's a
mechanism of finding what you need and
where to put it back and these labels
are actual stickers that we put on um
but it's really helpful for everyone in
the family to kind of you know identify
where things go it's really a lot harder
for your your spouse your partner or a
roommate to put things in the wrong area
if you have marked it correctly um is it
weird that i now find the fridge sexier
than the bedroom
no i don't actually i don't think i'm
literally like this is so hot
it's like my true honest feelings
now um the other night i'm staring at my
phone and i get a text from our dear
friend anthony suho
who is one of the heads of walmart and
you guys are crushing it there thank you
so much it's a dream it's a dream come
true so now that we can go get the home
edit
at walmart like thank you we're going to
organize all of the beautiful items
yes yes leah and joanna i love you guys
so much don't forget to catch season two
of get organized with the home edit
streaming on netflix now i am proud to
be on one of their episodes thank you
for having me
[Music]